let's pick up on our caller from the
four to five area code who's calling
today from four to five hey David
this is Burke hitter from Everett
Washington how are you hello I'm well
thank you
well my main question is everybody's
been paying attention to the fact that
he was held the four hundred million
dollars before he called the cranium
president right who demand some
investigations into Joe Biden and his
son but at the end of this supposed
transcript which is just a memorandum of
notes of the phone call was released he
he they should have not so veiled threat
which said you have many assets he said
you have many assets I have many friends
in the Ukraine I mean it's like it's
like basically coming out and saying if
you don't comply will freeze your assets
I mean I don't know if you've noticed
that the press has been completely
ignoring well and it still alone we're
still going through it but listen it
there is no question that that phone
call was the culmination of something
that had started long before so you have
as I said you have to go into it
understanding that it's not going to be
a one phone call even if we had a
word-for-word transcript it would not
tell the entire picture number one and
there would be all sorts of references
to things that we would not fully
understand because there is so much lead
up to it so of course of I mean listen
to you right it's exactly what we
predicted hello oh hello okay I guess we
lost them
alright that does it for phone calls for
today I do apologize to everybody I
didn't get to but I will be streaming on
Twitch tonight if you want another
opportunity to call in twitch.tv slash
David Pakman we will take a quick break
and be back with more right after this